alors limiers le cas selon vous est le
client idéal pour une interview alerte
aux roses à lagord c'est des petits
jeunes de dakar il ya un mouvement va
s'élargir titre là bien là les filles
vous êtes prête interview alerte rose
olivier stress que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer c'est d'une
complexité de trucks intellectuelle moi
j'ai besoin de faire l'amour quand j'en
ai envie
oui je vous avais besoin de boire pour
avoir cias d'avoir soif pour boire c'est
pas du moment comme quoi voilà est-ce
que vous préférez une femme qui baissent
bien mais qui est infidèle ou une femme
qui dose mal mais qui est fidèle
je crois que vraiment fond celle qui
baisent mal déjà elle sort ouais donc le
problème réglé ils ont messi vs bien si
elle est infidèle c'est pas un drame
ouais c'est un drame vous préféreriez
que votre femme couche avec un autre en
pensant à vous vous couchez avec vous en
france en un autre je préfère qu'ils
couchent avec shannon à gérer mais non
en fait je m'en fous non mais vraiment
vous êtes en train de me poser des
questions sur un très beau but mais
qu'est ce que j'avais vu la mer
en amour vous êtes partisan de tout
savoir ou de rien se dire en plus
l'amour étant pas spécialement parlant
pour moi je vois pas pourquoi on saurait
tout on dirait mais quelque chose vous
avez pas qu'on vous raconte ces gens
vient le mec était formidable et tout ça
c'est passé 18h30 à 21h
j'ai perdu les clés de la voiture d'une
femme algérien faire ça ne regarde pas
entre les chercheurs
j'estime que ce que fait l'autre ne me
regarde pas vous voulez mais vous et
maintenant je pense qu'on serait
tranquille tous les deux vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000
femmes toujours de la même façon
ou avec une femme de mille façons
différentes
c'est appétissant comme une pâtisserie
comme on accorde à 50 selon le vab
toujours de la même façon et où une
femme de mille façons différentes
incapable de choisir avec eux non non je
joue mon jeu de toutes les façons avec
1000 femmes où je vous sais pas
moi je secoue et tout d'un coup j'ai
autant parlé l'année puis 10 ans la télé
pour vous mais reste de moins frais
appareil je ne sais pas alors si alors
que c'est inepte
donc je vais pas je suis tout à fait
perplexe je réponds dans trois mois
d'accord becker d'abord grâce à
l'organisme est ce que vous l'avez déjà
fait dans l'eau très précieux au bord de
la mer c'est quand même pratique c'est
la chambre d'hôtel la moins chère
insérez le sel ça vous irrite pas
maintenant le sel il se dépose après un
préféré une femme comprend sans la
comprendre où une femme qu'on comprend
sans la prendre c'est de prendre un
groupe un an thaï hall salle ont perdu
tout mais moi je n'arrive pas vous
m'excuserez du cher thierry par
comprendre ces mécanismes l'am neiges
femme qu'on comprend déjà c'est héroïque
dont le reste est en réalité
oh la la
si votre femme vous trompez février que
ce soir avec un homme ou avec une femme
avec qui elles veulent un son problème
vous ai déjà dit moi ouais l'autre fait
ce qu'il veut ça me regarde pas je vais
quand même pas être la paix carton rouge
c'est une grande aide non ça me regarde
pas est-ce que se faire sucer c'est
tromper
oh non